for everyone who's listening if you can
compliment a kid totally
especially one that you're not related
to this yeah for just the answer no for
this well for this you own who you are
it's funny I talk a lot about when
you're reinforcing positivity to kids
around grades their athleticism or how
attractive they are it makes them
vulnerable because their self-worth
becomes in that and all of those three
things kind of change over time like
most kids don't play professional sports
totally most people realize somewhere
around 23 that uh oh grades mean nothing
in real life and if you're fighting for
like looking beautiful as a man or woman
it's a constant game of insecurity
because all of us age like you know it's
just you know it's really hard so to
your point you're complimenting kids on
their energy their Ambitions their
kindness their grit and the words coming
out of their mouth